hello and welcome i'm james murphy and today we're
going to be looking at what's the fastest way to
loop in python so just as an example task we're
going to loop through the numbers 0 to n minus 1
where n is going to be some big number like this
and just add them up you know something to do in
the loop which one do you think is faster using a
while loop or a for loop you can see in both cases
we're doing essentially the same work but one of
them is using a while loop and the other one is
using a for loop in both cases we initialize a sum
to zero and then loop over all the numbers adding
to the sum we'll test to see which one is fastest
by using the timeit method from the timeit library
let's just go ahead and run it okay and you can
already see that it took a surprising amount of
time over 15 seconds for the while loop but just
under 10 seconds for the for loop so it looks like
the for loop is the clear winner in this case
i would like to point out that i am recording
this at the same time that i'm running this code
so these numbers are largely inflated but if you
run the code at home and i have done this you will
find that the ratios are approximately the same
so we saw that although the for loop and the
while loop are doing essentially the same thing
the while loop took over five seconds longer why
is that well the unfortunate fact of the matter
is that compared to the c programming language
that python is written in python itself is an
extremely slow language in order to do the
for loop python passes the iteration off to
c code that works with the iterator of this
range object that's all written in c so all
of the iteration part of it is actually done
in c all the bounds checking and incrementing
of this variable i is done in c and it's only
this statement which is actually done in python
in contrast in the while loop both the check to
see whether i is less than n and incrementing i
both of those things are done in python not
in c we can confirm that this is actually the
issue by adding in these functions so what
these functions do these are modifications
of this for loop function that add in a redundant
operation that doesn't actually need to be there
so in this one we add in the increment
so we increment i now of course
this variable i is going to be incremented
by the range iterator on its own so this i
plus equals 1 actually has no noticeable
effect besides running and taking up time
similarly in this one we add in this redundant
check to see whether i is less than n and then
in this one we add in both the check to see if
i is less than n and the redundant increment so
i've just given them their own lines in the timeit
code and let's go ahead and run it again and see
how long they take so as you can see just adding
in these redundant operations to the for loop
implementation that it significantly increased
the time this i plus equals 1 shouldn't really do
anything but adding that in alone has practically
made the for loop as slow as the while loop
similarly we can see that adding in the redundant
if i is less than n check also adds a few seconds
to the computation then worst of all is doing
both the redundant i plus equals 1 and test to
see if i is less than n that's coming in at
around 19 seconds making it the slowest one
and showing us that doing these useless operations
just because they're in python and not in c even
though they have no real effect is really slowing
our code down okay that's pretty sad so is there
anything that we can do to go faster than a for
loop or a while loop one thing that should come
to mind is use built-ins over loops whenever
you can so this implementation uses the built-in
sum which does a for loop under the hood uh
and the built-in range of course rather than
writing the loop ourselves so let's see how fast
that goes wow that is a lot better than both the
for loop and the while loop so you can see if
ever you have the ability to use a built-in
over an actual loop you should definitely take
that route but can we do even better than that
how about let's try using numpy which is built
for doing these kind of operations quickly
i went ahead and imported numpy and added this
sum numpy function the numpy sum just creates
the range as a numpy range and then uses the
numpy.sum to sum it up so this is essentially
equivalent to this one but it's using numpy
functions instead of python functions and again
numpy is primarily written in c so as much of this
as possible should be happening in c not python
let's try running it again okay so that one was
much faster compared to the others this is the
only good one because the entire summing operation
is written in c this whole function essentially
is one c call so both the iteration but also the
adding itself is done in c and that's what makes
this one the fastest of them all the only downside
to this one is that this creation of a range
actually creates that whole array in memory
so i just made a 100 million element array in
memory so if i had chosen a bigger number
i might not have enough memory to do that
comparatively this sum range this range doesn't
actually create all those elements in memory
so this sum could actually run no matter how big
n is without worrying about memory constraints
but in this case i think it's definitely worth
it to give up the memory and let the sum happen
in c rather than python so you might be
asking is there anything that we can do
to beat out numpy you would be hard-pressed
to find a faster implementation even in c
for this sum operation i think numpy does a really
good job at making this happen quickly so the only
feasible way of making this happen faster is
to know the answer ahead of time that's why the
final implementation is to use math knowledge what
are we doing we're adding up the first n minus 1
integers well there's a formula for that you may
not know it but you can certainly look it up and
here it is so this is pure python and it's going
to beat out the c one for sure by a lot let's go
ahead and test it and of course it is no contest
the pure math implementation is not even in the
same league numpy is good but knowing the answer
ahead of time you just can't compete with that
in conclusion what's the fastest way to loop
in python well the unfortunate truth of the
matter is the fastest way to loop in python
is not to loop in python if you have the
great luxury of being able to compute the answer
mathematically ahead of time definitely do that
your next best option is to have the whole looping
and everything that you want to do be done in a
pure c function your next best option is to call
a pure c function that can do all of the looping
and your operations for you failing that
use python built-ins like sum or map
rather than writing a loop yourself as a last
resort use a for loop over a while loop hey thanks
for watching if you liked the video don't forget
to leave a like a comment and if you especially
liked the video don't forget to subscribe it
really helps me out thanks see you in the next one